dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr karo jonay feher
approximately five months ago we talked
about a technique called
neural radiance fields or nerf in short
that worked on a 5d neural radiance
field representation so
what does this mean exactly what this
means is that we have three dimensions
for location
and two for view direction or in short
the input is where we are in space give
it to a neural network to learn it
and synthesize new previously unseen
views
of not just the materials in the scene
but the entire scene itself
in short it can learn and reproduce
entire real-world scenes
from only a few views by using neural
networks
and the results were just out of this
world look
it could deal with many kinds of matte
and glossy materials
and even refractions worked quite well
it also understood
depth so accurately that we could use it
for
augmented reality applications where we
put a new
virtual object in the scene and it
correctly determined
whether it is in front of or behind the
real objects in the scene
however not everything was perfect in
many cases it had trouble with scenes
with variable lighting conditions
and lots of occluders you might ask
is that really a problem well imagine a
use case of a tourist attraction that a
lot of people take photos of
and we then have a collection of photos
taken
during a different time of the day and
of course
with a lot of people around but hey
remember that this means an application
where we have
exactly these conditions a wide variety
of illumination changes
and occluders this is exactly what nerf
was not too good at
let's see how it did on such a case
yes we see both abrupt changes in the
illumination
and the remnants of the forks occluding
the brandenburg gate as well
and this is where this new technique
from scientists at google research
by the name nerf w shines it takes
such a photo collection and tries to
reconstruct the whole scene from it
which we can again render from new
viewpoints
so how well did the new method do in
this case
let's see wow
just look at how consistent those
results are
so much improvement in just 6 months of
time
this is unbelievable this is how it did
in a similar case with the trevi
fountain
absolutely beautiful and what is even
more beautiful
is that since it has variation in the
viewpoint information
we can change these viewpoints around as
the algorithm learned to reconstruct the
scene
itself this is something that the
original nerf technique could also do
however what it couldn't do is the same
with
illumination now we can also change the
lighting conditions together with the
viewpoint
this truly showcases a deep
understanding of illumination
and geometry that is not trivial
at all for instance when loading this
scene into this neural re-rendering
technique from last year
it couldn't tell whether we see just
color variations on the same geometry
or if the geometry itself is changing
and look this new technique does much
better
on cases like this
so clean now that we have seen the
images let's see what the numbers say
for these scenes the nrw is the neural
re-rendering technique we just saw
and the other one is the nerf paper from
this year the abbreviations show
different ways of computing the output
images the up and down arrows show
whether they are subject to maximization
or minimization
they are both relatively close but when
we look at the new method
we see one of the rare cases where it
wins decisively
regardless of what we are measuring
incredible
this paper is truly a great leap in just
a few months
but of course not everything is perfect
here the technique may fail to
reconstruct regions that are only
visible on just a few photos in the
input data set the training still takes
from hours to days
i take this as an interesting detail
more than a limitation
since the training only has to be done
once and then
using the technique can take place very
quickly but
with that there you go a neural
algorithm that
understands lighting geometry can
disentangle the two
and reconstruct real-world scenes from
just a few
photos it truly feels like we are living
in a science fiction world
what a time to be alive what you see
here is an instrumentation for a
previous paper
that we covered in this series which was
made by weights and biases
i think organizing these experiments
really showcases
the usability of their system weights
and biases provides tools to track your
experiments
in your deep learning projects their
system is designed to save you a ton of
time
and money and it is actively used in
projects at prestigious labs
such as open ai toyota research github
and more and the best part is that if
you have an open source
academic or personal project you can use
their tools for free
it really is as good as it gets make
sure to visit them through wnb.com
papers or click the link in the video
description
to start tracking your experiments in
five minutes
our thanks to weights and biases for
their long-standing support
and for helping us make better videos
for you thanks for watching and for your
generous support
and i'll see you next time